left-hander robbie ray this afternoon he
is your d-back starting pitcher and
robbie going for a milestone hopefully
very early in the ball game only three
strikeouts away from 1000 for his career
swinging and a miss and there's
strikeout number 998 for robbie ray as
he gets grisham to start the ballgame
one down man
down and he misses so a one-off walk for
manny machado you end up walking him in
front of this guy
yeah this guy is fernando tantes jr
hitting 310 with nine home runs
double play ball here ahmed kittell
and they just do roll the double play
garrett richards on the mound today for
the padres in his fifth start era 374
opponents hitting 250 250 against him
it's cole calhoun the dh gets first look
this one is sharply hit back up the
middle ranging his tatties through
the green but in time nice play by
fernando tatis
here's cattell
on the ground to second base cronenberg
to first and there are two outs here in
the first inning harris starling marta
chops this one to third and machado
plays the big hop oh how about that
garrett richards three ground outs one
two three diamondbacks when i walk in
the second right here i'll bring up jake
cronenworth
fam swinging a miss there's the
strikeout and they cannot get a runner
at second base
999 career strikeouts for rodney red
rookie edward oliveira's in right field
allison again this one ricochets a long
way away and heading to third base is
fam
live ball left field peralta is going to
have to hustle to get to the corner
and david's got it in front of the
bullpen robbie at 999 career strikeouts
let's see if he can get career strikeout
number 1000 right here well there's 1
000 career strikeouts for robbie ray a
career milestone for robbie here today
fewest games to a thousand career
strikeouts among left-handers all time
the second fastest ever among lefties
behind only his big brother randy
johnson garrett richards back to work
it's been a very quick first two innings
for garrett jay swings floats one into
shallow center going back and making the
catch cronenworth ian tatis with a
little bit of a mild collision i'd call
it unfortunately everybody appears to be
okay
i'm sure everybody in the padre
organization was holding their breath on
that one time banks have a base runner
two outs down at the top of the order
and cole calhoun flipped it to left
field hit it pretty well pangos mateo at
the warning track off the wall touch
them all core calhoun that's his fifth
in the last 10 games and the
diamondbacks shoot on top here on the
third inning two to nothing a little
two-out thunder here from the d-backs
thanks to the infield single and now a
rocket shot down the right-field line so
runners on the corners two down and the
number eight hitter nick ahmed coming up
now the o1 pitch and ahmed swings hits
it in the air to right field old ivaras
over towards the gap now back a step he
makes a two-handed catch and the inning
is over walking the ball he's getting
away with it so far robbie ray you're
living large kid first and second with
two walks in the inning the padres still
don't have a base hit but they're
flirting with trouble right here and
here comes manny machado he's swinging a
miss he struck him out to end the inning
so robbie dials up a big strikeout his
fourth of the ball game five no hit
innings bobby ray who's not allowed to
hit fernando tatis junior to lead it off
and that is ball four so a lead-off walk
for fernando tatis junior six walks
allowed by robbie ray
gotta go get him right tory lavello
robbie ray despite the fact he is not
allowed to hit today his day is over
junior guerra coming in here casmere
will be the hitter here in the air to
right center field for hosmer back it
goes at the wall it is gone
cosmo with a two-run home run ties this
game two to two with one swim in the
back
well don there goes the no-hitter there
goes the shutout in a big hit
for the padres first and third with
nobody out padres great opportunity here
to get the lead here's josh naylor who
will bat for oliveira's reaches out and
poops this to right center field that is
falling fast and that ball is going to
fall in from third base to score is
tommy pham and the padres take a 3-2
lead josh naylor just back with the
padres drives in the go ahead run for
san diego still with nobody out here's
hedges shows bunt gets it down coming
home
vote applies the tag on conan worth and
they cut down that lead man at the plate
second walk of the inning in the eighth
of the afternoon issued by arizona so
runners on first and second one out for
tommy pham here's the 1-1 pitch fam
breaks his back grounds it into the left
side it'll be the shortstop ahmed trying
to go to third and he threw it away into
the dugout i don't get a run home padres
take a 4-2 lead and only once this year
so far has a padre starter completed
seven garrett richards got a shot he's
out here in the bottom of the seventh
inning ground ball to the right side
could be two flipped to second for one
tatis's turn in time double play inning
over garrett richard does get through
seven two on now for eduardo escobar a
lot of work this week all weekend long
early hitting with darnell cole trying
to make that work pay off right here
escobar
deep right field
say goodbye
it's been a long time coming eduardo
escobar and de
diamondbacks and now archie bradley who
got knocked around last night going to
try and hold a one-run lead for the
d-backs and tatis the tying runs 90 feet
away with two outs here's zombie fan
coming back with a fastball foul back
out of play
pam hurt himself but jace tingler comes
out to check on it look like he shook
his wrist after this swing he is coming
out with an injury now with the ball and
two strikes
it'll be greg garcia
not the ideal position as a pitch hitter
but uh you know you got to do what you
got to do got him
diamondbacks sweeps san diego
they have won four straight eight of
their last 11.